hey there i'm chloe bailey and i'm here
with my friends at tasty to kick off the
summer with some of the sweetest notes
and straight fire thanks to my
make them sweat hot sauce
this sauce is an exclusive collab with
doordash and brings a perfect dash of
sweet and a whole lot of heat like me
the limited edition hot sauce will be
available only to dashpat's members on
the doordash app let's check out what
our friends at tasty have cooked up my
inspiration for this hot sauce i love a
lot of spice but i also love a lot of
sweet and it's like a combination of
everything that makes me me in hot sauce
form
the name make them sweat is kind of how
i live my life you got to add a little
pressure sometimes make it hot make them
sweat i think i can handle a good amount
of spice but i also wanted it to have
like a little flavor other than just the
regular cayenne pepper hot sauce and
it's my favorite because i can put it on
anything
i'm from the south so my nana my mom my
aunts and uncles they would always make
the best southern food i love how food
can bring people together it's like when
you share memories and moments i love
this song i have called treat me because
it reminds me of food in a way like
treat me like i treat me i'm gonna make
my stomach my soul my body my mind
everything happy i have carried hot
sauce in my bag a few times like the
little sample little ones i love those i
will be carrying my makeup sweat hot
sauce in my bag thanks to our friends at
tasty for this beautiful dish make sure
to go to the doordash app and check out
my limited edition hot sauce available
exclusively to dash pass members sign up
today for dash pass doordash's
membership program where you can get
free delivery access to amazing
exclusives like our new hot sauce
one-of-a-kind menu items and more
[Music]
[Music]